the three hatchlings are voiced by an  incredible group of young actors  Brooklyn prince from the Florida Project  plays Zoe Genesis tenon plays vivvy in  Elma ver Sano plays Sam Sam the  hatchling voices are so cute because  they're real kids and I think the charm  is that they sound like kids because  they are kids we would have kids that  were as young as two and a half stepping  up to the mic and doing these great  performances and then Jojo see WA agreed  to do a voice mommy did you get my pitch  did you get it mom she's got so much  energy and it has this little raspy  voice and I think it just makes her pop  I was just so happy because I've never  done a feature film before so what  better way to jump into the future film  world than the most adorable and awesome  animation ever read here has got your  back and your front and your sides and  my flu yeah even your cute little fools  like you're gonna be okay  [Music]